l'acteur Alec Baldwin sera accusé
domicile involontaire dans l'état du
Nouveau-Mexique parce que lors du
tournage du film Rust en 2021 la
directrice de la photographie Aliana
Hodgins 42 ans est morte et il y a un
réalisateur aussi qui était blessé après
avoir été touché l'un et l'autre par le
tir d'un fusil manipulé par Baldwin qui
était également le producteur de ce film
là l'armurière qui travaillait sur le
tournage va faire elle aussi face à des
accusations similaires il y a une
assistant réalisateur qui a plaid
coupable à des accusations d'usage
négligeants d'une arme mortelle alors
pour en parler on reçoit Charles Côté
bonjour Charles bonjour Isabelle alors
c'est arrivé en 2021 en octobre 21 on
annonce aujourd'hui des accusations qui
seront déposées bientôt à la fin du mois
15 mois c'est quand même long comme pour
enquête pour enquêter là-dessus non on
parle d'une enquête qui a duré environ
une année au niveau des forces
policières et trois mois pour les
services juridiques du procureur
d'analyser l'ensemble de la preuve de
l'enquête et décider si
et quelles accusations seraient déposées
dans la présentation alors on en a
retenu deux contre Monsieur Baldwin deux
chefs domicile involontaires il y a une
petite nuance entre les deux pourquoi
ces deux là pourquoi deux d'ailleurs il
y a de ce que je comprends et je vais
faire une traduction libre des chefs
d'accusation parce que on a rien
similaire comme ça comparable en droit
canadien c'est négligence criminelle sur
quelque chose de comparable mais et
l'autre ce serait
négligeant ce criminelle dans
l'utilisation d'une arme à feu alors
c'est ce qui fait la différence et la
différence est assez notable parce que
la simple négligence criminelle
impliquerait 18 mois de d'emprisonnement
maximum tandis que avec l'utilisation
dans dans l'utilisation d'une arme à feu
ou avec l'utilisation ça importe une
peine minimale de 5 ans ah oui en effet
c'est pas du tout la même chose
aujourd'hui la procureur du district a
dit que le fait que ce soit un accident
ne veut pas veut dire qu'aucun acte
criminel n'a été commis moi je trouvais
ça un peu contradictoire mais je
comprends ce que veut dire un accident
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on veut alors
il y a pas de volonté de tirer sur sur
la dame la victime qui est morte mais
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on a qu'on
l'accusé de domicile est volontaire
plutôt par exemple que de négligence
criminelle comme l'autre accusé
que ce sera à la poursuite de justifier
son choix d'accusation c'est
effectivement surprenant après ma barre
parce que une accusation de domicile et
volontaire c'est de commettre un geste
avec une inscience face à ce qui va
arriver et que masse ensuite
la personne le meilleur exemple c'est au
cours d'une bataille l'opposant tombe à
terre se fracture le crâne sur le sol et
en décède alors ça c'est effectivement
le plus bel exemple d'un homme c'est
volontaire coupable bon Baldwin il le
dit lui qu'on lui avait dit que l'arme
qui l'utilisait qu'on lui remettait
n'était pas chargé de vraies balles et
donc il n'avait pas l'obligation de
vérifier ce qui avait dedans mais dire
qu'on s'est fié à ce que quelqu'un
d'autre nous a dit est-ce que c'est une
bonne défense est-ce que ça tient mais
c'est un doute raisonnable qu'on doit
soulever à procès alors dans ce cas-ci
il faut comprendre que la chaîne de
trans de la fameuse arme a passé par
deux les mains de deux personnes avant
d'arriver à l'acteur alors il y a la
première personne qui l'armurière et
accessoiriste dans dans ce cas-ci elle
avait les deux rôles et c'était ses
fonctions spécifiques de s'assurer que
l'arme était sécuritaire et non pas
chargé de vrais balles de toute façon
sur les lieux de tournage les vrais
munitions sont interdites et prohibées
alors elle devait faire cette
vérification là et à l'assistant
réalisateur qui lui reçoit l'arme
également doit s'assurer bon cette
arme-là est conforme auprès de
l'armurière et en confirme sa sécurité
auprès de l'acteur est-ce qu'on va
demander à l'acteur de s'assurer que
tous les les accessoires qu'il va
utiliser sont conformes et sécuritaire
comme un cascadeur qui va utiliser une
voiture s'assurer que les frais ou même
un acteur qui va conduire un véhicule
s'assurer que les freins sont
fonctionnent je pense que pousser la
responsabilité oui évidemment je parle à
l'avocat de la défense la procureur en
chef a dit que c'était vraiment le
désordre sur le tournage il y avait des
munitions réelles il y avait des balles
à blanc donc on voit ici le problème
éventuel il y avait des mesures de
sécurité inadéquate personne a bien fait
son travail alors on se dit est-ce que
ça ça l'aide ou l'inverse ben c'est
évident que par son rôle de producteur
c'est là ça va peut-être lui causer un
peu nuit problème mais était-il vraiment
impliqué au niveau de la production
lorsqu'on regarde le générique d'un film
il y a il y en a tellement là mais il
était producteur il était producteur
c'est de savoir jusqu'à quel point il
avait une responsabilité légale de
s'assurer qu'à ce moment précis l'arme
qu'on lui tendait comme étant en
sécurité
Charles Côté merci infiniment ça me fait
plaisir au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]